ils ont l'habitude de se préparer au
combat mais dans la guerre contre la
coved 19
la préparation est exceptionnel c'est ça
que nous on est considéré un métier de
combat donc tout ce qui est relié au
médical on n'est pas habitué à ça c'est
un peu nouveau pour nous la cavalière
aurélie boily s'apprête à aider en ch
est celle d une toute autre réalité que
celle de son blindé habituels comme pour
sa collègue ariel gagnon c'est une
première on tape une arme et on lui je
me présente pour se préparer à l'inconnu
même si pelletier infirmières dans les
forces armées canadiennes leur donne une
formation de base de 5 heures pour
qu'ils puissent soutenir le personnel de
santé dont on va leur montrer comment
supporter pour l'alimentation
comment aider le personnel sur place a
mobilisé les patients ça peut être de
l'entretien ménager pour s'assurer que
les choses sont prêts at her en même
temps on utilise nos soldats dans ce
qu'ils sont meilleurs un stade à dire la
force d'adaptation des fantassins des
réservistes ou des étudiants ils ont
levé la main devant l'ampleur de la
crise la formation comprend un volet de
préparation pour la santé mentale des
gens qui vont aller aider justement
parce qu'ils voient confrontés à des
situations qui sont pas habitués dans un
rôle où une seule ne sont pas habitués
n'ont à la base militaire de saison soit
un lieu où on forme environ 150
militaires par jour pour pouvoir les
déployer dans l'essai à chasser l'idée
il ya également des formations du côté
de québec et c'est évidemment pour
répondre à l'appel du premier ministre
le beau on me dit que 400 militaires
devrait arriver mercredi
donc après demain puis devrait en avoir
un autre 275 qui vont suivre
mais son impôt la date encore de l'est
connu il y en a encore on ignore dans
quel établissement ils seront envoyés
c'est le ministère de la santé du québec
qui établit les priorités
ici on attend les ordres
et si jacques ory charbonneau radio
canada sur la base militaire de
saint-jean-sur-richelieu